[Música]
uai
uma pena
[Música]
ontem todos os dias por semana apenas
uma pena a cumprir uma pena similar mas
foram 21 dias
[Música]
neste vídeo não só com um golaço que meu
filho que eu sei que é impossível mas de
qualquer forma eu vou gravar este local
estamos à beira do lago ii colóquio de
pessoal de quem for mudar que seja muito
menos a mais um vídeo que é porque eu
estou como no filme a mão luvas de
proteção óculos de proteção porque
pessoal porque hoje nós vamos construir
ainda mais potentes a mais exclusiva é
mais campeão de todos os tempos e isso
foi pequeno jardim da casa pois é e como
é que nós vamos fazer isso pessoal
apenas precisamos de um anexo do vários
explosivos e eu vou mostrar
sabe aquelas ver uma imagem que os tipos
de r potter que elas lançam tipo vara
exclusiva enfim eu tenho aqui quatro
dessas varinhas e cada varinha tem 30
disparos ou seja 34 da 30 60 70 mais 120
cento e vinte de espaço inclusive com
isso é muito fácil misteriosa muito
fácil e acho eu não sei o que eu vou
explodir com isso mas eu vou agarrar
isso a nossa nery e vamos disparar
quando todos exclusivos
vai ser incrível e é por isso que nossa
análise faz
é mais exclusiva mais incrível mas o
tento de sempre
e vocês vão acompanhar tudo com esta
câmara é mais misterioso está a filmar
vão acompanhar também como eu próprio
vou colocar aqui - diego nosso álbum eu
vou demonstrar vem vai levar esta que
meus amigos quero que o pessoal é o
senhor reclamar eleitor
nós vamos estar aqui exclusivista vamos
ver se conseguimos acertar a prova vai
ser eu próprio vou colocar aqui e depois
da eleição eu vou ver se conseguia
separar não porque muitos destes
explosivos têm um corpo e os nós
conseguimos ver o ônibus outros não só
eles são o mesmo portanto é comprovável
ajudar a imensa descobrir se você tem ou
não mas nós em casa já vão ver tudo pelo
poder importante é só comentários vocês
viram esse padrão não tem enquanto vocês
acham que ela está em obras em 126 cv e
eu devo conseguir acertar onde 10 no
mínimo a isso com mais fé eu aposto 4044
assim só comentei quando é que vocês
acham que vou conseguir acertar
lembrando que está aqui são explosivos
portanto sai de forma muito irregular
porque isso não está está pobre 90 e
sair de qualquer jeito sai com deve
entrar nós temos também como alvo o cob
o suzuki olha aí tem muito colocar aí é
o cão eu sinceramente agora assim fora
do vídeo é o cão que mais carga no mundo
nunca vi um cara mais a voz misteriosa
mas enfim só voltou a construir a maior
e mais potente mais clean energy todos
os tempos para preparar a equipe para
que estas luvas de proteção elas evitam
cortes lâminas evitar explosões e viram
tudo
são excelentes para este tipo de coisas
mas eu vou deixar aqui do lado porque é
preciso construir
eu tenho quatro exclusivos portanto
vamos ganhar aqui fora é que fique mais
ou menos um aqui
o outro é que vou ter que rolar assim
outra coisa importante como eu vou
colocar a mão aqui convém não só é feliz
que por trás portanto tem que colocar
mais à frente essa idéia é traçar um
site por que os restos de pobre e fumaça
quinta então tem que ter atenção
ok vai ficar mais ou menos assim e para
os tiros afunilarem mais precisamente
eu quero eu vou é postar aqui também que
em abril se ficarem bem juntinhos
então assim o tiro sai com mais precisão
espera o leste pelo eu soltar temos que
reduzir não vai continuar afirma tudo
vai correr bem o que era aquilo
cientista
o cientista político não fica lá filmar
é importante primeiro é o olho é isso
agora falta mais dois no estado meu deus
está a ficar incrível
falei hoje ninguém mais discute a
potência da nossa não foi fácil apertar
aqui um pouquinho agora é só estar
alinhado a mira está mesmo no cinto de
explosivos perfeita embora lá pra vocês
conseguirem também ver isso muito bem eu
vou colocar aqui eu próprio cima você
comprava estar na empresa
se acontecer um desastre possa ir embora
tecnicamente mas é preciso que fique lá
filmar isso não vai dar errado isso é
feito por isso mesmo ele é explosivo
está aqui somos todos profetas portanto
nada dar errado confia eu estou que eu
sou cientista não faz sempre disse ficar
longe de cozinha nada então eu faço
explosivos fazer nada
o o governo muito mãe incrível eles
burlavam está agora este vai ser um ano
visão que vocês vão ter pessoal estejam
preparados
é porque eu também estou então não dá
muito certo dar muito errado vamos ver o
que vai acontecer no primeiro primeiro
esquece um fator importante eu tenho que
abrir aqui o papel de segurança falta
isso
ao mesmo tempo eu vou ligar os assim ok
[Música]
o jô
só consegui se não está acompanhando
a banda inglesa volta não vai surgindo
com ele meu deus tem muita potência
[Música]
em meu peito não conseguir acertar dores
na cabeça mas o gol só muito
o cabo está aqui a pensar só acende um
porque eu não consegui ser mais foi
muita opção
acho que já acabou você quer dizer que
vamos tentar acelerar agora 23 e ver
como é que funcionam ao mesmo tempo
foi assim agora sim é bom para comprar
embora
meu deus o que é isso
op a câmera uma vez aparece volta
[Música]
sinto em mim quarta serei bom você
perguntar
é bom nos modo algum brasileiro
[Música]
op você olha aqui
uau incrível como é que esta missão voz
misteriosa foi assustadora assustadora
não foi claudio sucesso e agora vamos
ver o estado do nosso alvo após que tem
lá essas marcas de choque vamos ver para
lá olha precisamente tem aqui uma mãe
por isto o sim exato estou cheio de
pólvora e para sair as coisas deve ter
um componente químico também que deixará
coralina é portanto isso não ser humano
e magoar muito portanto não brinquem com
isso em casa cai porque temos aqui mais
é que imensos no pleito está aqui minhas
marcas olhar para cima e tenho aqui tem
outra aqui tem outra aqui outra aqui
o track outra no domingo numa mesmo com
meu filho aí vamos ver se eu conseguisse
estar na caixa a caixa não funcionou eo
funk e não só funcionam aqui o nosso
experimento com um cenário realmente ter
mais potente de todas com certeza que
vocês também já viram o choque da gopro
porque entretanto fiz na edição não é de
ficar incrível depois de viver enquanto
evita o vídeo e este todos aqui estão
muito quentes com muito quente mesmo
empreendimento está tão seguro como eu
calculei que fosse né porque não
explodiu para trás não explodiu assim
ator foi sempre frente tudo em linha
reta com diz as instruções claro que
isso é pra tirar notificar o procel que
é pra vocês não se magoarem mas eu
preferi fazer essa experiência aqui tudo
em ambiente controlado só portanto
reforça que mais uma vez não testamos em
casa só que eu posso fazer porque eu sei
que existam apenas teve tons rodar como
está sendo mais proteção eu tive que
tirar as luvas de proteção para
conseguir acender um isqueiro para
acender a que os que estavam porque
senão não ia acontecer e eu só sendo um
já sabe como é que vocês acharam deixei
muito líquido e partilhem com um dos
nossos limites no integrante não digo
nada apenas enviou o link somando eu
quero ver o que eles vão dizer acerca de
e só fiquem bem e até a próxima